tente traditionnelle caravane optimisé
ou bungalows suréquipés en camping
chacun trouve son bonheur sur ce site 4
étoiles de maisons laffitte les
vacanciers arrivent timidement une
fréquentation impactés par le mauvais
temps de ce printemps et la crainte des
attentats
on mise donc sur le dialogue pour
assurer de dire qu'en fait justement les
les services de l'état fonds nécessaires
pour donc bien organiser la sécurité que
nous avons donc les garantie annulation
que
voilà nos services ici sur place pour
donc les clients et est au rendez-vous
et que donc on peut les renseigner ou
cet intéressant d'y aller voir donc des
biens les rançons charles de gaulle
étoile situe à proximité de paris
l'établissement vise une clientèle
étrangère et propose des mobiles homes
haut de gamme
mais début juin le camping a été touché
par les intempéries 400 personnes ont
été évacuées par sécurité
par endroits l'eau est montée jusqu'à 70
cm par précaution nous avons donc
évacuer le camping mais également on a
en a décidé de mettre en sécurité
certains locatif ici donc présents
pour éviter donc la casse matérielle qui
est très cher et ça à quatre jours avant
l'euro donc
c'était très attention à rambouillet
même constat les inondations ont obligé
le site a fermé une semaine au mois de
juin
les touristes étrangers sont moins
nombreux aujourd'hui en tout cas on a
une tendance qui va être un petit peu à
la baisse sur la partie étrangère
entre les attentats les intempéries et
les grèves et les sur la tendance sur le
bassin parisien et elle a été beaucoup
plus faible justement au niveau 2 de nos
arrivées on peut palier c'est ça me
paraît évident malgré un début de saison
mitigé les professionnels espèrent
doubler leur fréquentation dès la
semaine prochaine
le camping reste le mode de vacances
préférées des français
en 2015 le pays affiche à un record de
fréquentation avec près de 113 millions
de nuitées